so nine years ago I quit my job as a
cryonics plan you know for those people
who want to freeze themselves for a
thousand years hoping to wake up in a
better world
my job was to make sure there are frozen
bodies would stay safe and sound for all
that long
no pressure right I mean how do you even
design a building to last for a
millennial well what if there's a zombie
apocalypse or a giant Media or another
Global pandemic how do you guarantee
your clients will end up as popsicles
for some Alien Invaders or in a zoo
I mean given that nothing lasts forever
what is a literally sustainable design
well good luck finding any answers on
the internet
most of what you'll find a bunch of
greenwashing products programs that
claim to be equal friendly but they're
actually just as bad if not worse than
status quo I mean they promise to have a
net zero impact but they don't tell you
how they measure that or what they do
with the waste or how they exploit the
workers or how they brought the
politicians I mean they don't care about
your future they primarily care about
their profit
what maybe just about give up though was
when I was working on a huge map for San
Antonio a map that showed all the
infrastructure planned and the exist
a map that revealed a shock and truth
and 25 of the pipes underground they're
old they're rot they're leaking cracking
burst in contaminating the water supply
they were violating the Clean Water Act
and the city was facing like a billion
dollar fire how do you explain that to
the voters how do you tell them they
have to focus over billions of dollars
for something they never asked never see
never care about how do you tell them
they have to pay for flush and toilets
you know so that's the earning question
how do we create a truly sustainable
human you know world where we don't ruin
everything for ourselves and our kids
however we don't have to worry about
climate change solution or Extinction
a world where we can have a harmonious
story between us of nature
after a year I was so stressed out by
this question and I decided to seek some
spiritual guidance I ended up cooking
breakfast for this Tibetan monk he was
very nice very wise very bald
but over some scrambled eggs and coffee
he asked me what was bothering me what
did I want to learn I babbled on about
my interest in impermanence fraction
geometry psychology storytelling and he
stopped and he said storytelling
that's it that research needs to be done
so I did I put my job in the back of my
cats and I moved to Cyprus here I read a
lot of books and articles and I came
across this amazing story about two
Australian researchers who were
following a song line now a song Allah
it turns out it's like an epic GPS the
app original people used to navigate the
land they sing the stories and if
they're going in the right direction the
landforms along the way correspond to
the characters in the store
okay so the years 2014 and these
researchers are walking along singing
their little hearts out when suddenly
they're standing in the sea they thought
they messed up somehow maybe they took a
wrong turn at the Berlin bush
but then they realized maybe this song
continues under the water
and sure enough they found the rest of
the land box submerged in the sea on
oceanic shots this song line was so old
it dated back to the last ice age when
the sea level was at
this song line had survived for like 10
500 years passed down by word mouth for
at least 500 Generations
now that's longer than any cryotics
project I've dreamed of probably more
fun
well this blew my mind how come we use
this ancient technology to shape off
future maybe we could leverage
continuity going backwards to go
forwards but how can we tell our stories
to the land like that and make them
stick
well it turns out it's just that simple
you need to map your stories you know
the stories you tell yourself or your
friends or your therapists no meaningful
Stories the stories that make up who you
are and where you come from all those
stories that was setting and a setting
can be mapped
imagine our stories like a tapestry and
when we laid them out on the land we
could see other threads of each other's
stories intertwine and how they target
each other how they harmonize now with
this knowledge we can spend no tales
that build upon the old you know like
weaving New threads to fill in the worn
holes of that texture
and math and asteroids isn't just for
personal Insight we could use them to
guide decisions about our neighborhoods
climate immigration Business Development
isolation we can make sure that
everything we do is in harmony with our
stories well or at least not
contradicted
now just to live together we need to
know where each other are coming from
the Aboriginal people of Australia
showed me that the stories mixed with
the land can last for thousands of years
so so using stories of the people here
in famagusta I made a prototype of a map
of stories you know that you know we and
our descendants could adapt and evolved
stories that could last for ten thousand
years or more
now we all know there are gaps in the
structures that support our society in
order to enable communities to plug
those caps we need to build a narrative
infrastructure now one that Maps stories
and communities across the world with
narrative tools and GIS we can create a
narrative infrastructure for the future
a future that's not on ice but a lie
with stories
thank you very much